So, I think I will get in long.
My stop's going to be a little bigger
here.
It's choppy. So, I need to give a pretty
wide stop.
I'm going to get in long here on this
break.
It' be [clears throat] nice to see a
little bit of a pullback, but you know,
just have this candle pull back a little
bit and then continue. But, it's still a
good spot. order.
>> I like the signal.
It is choppy,
but pushing the overnight highs I think
is solid. I would have I think I would
have preferred to wait for this pullback
here to continue like just even just
like literally a couple point pullback
here
just because seeing how this candlestick
uh the market reacts to that.
I don't want to move up yet. This this
bottom little here.
Definitely like a potential of like, oh,
maybe I should move up there. But I
think I just got to let I got to let it
play out a little bit more. I need a
little like one more break higher.
If we just kind of do this where we're
just kind of trending and I can move up
with pullbacks because we could get up
here and then start slow down, do a
little bit of pullback, flag out and
then continue the trend to the upside
and I would love to be in on that
because the market's been trendy. And
so, but to do that, you know, I'm going
to have to hold through some pullbacks.
And so, I now we've hit 1x. That's just
kind of my my spot for moving my stop
up. I'm just going to move it up here
just because that's kind of a nice
um you know, it totally might pull back
to this area where it had kind of some
a little bit of resistance.
You know, we're kind of reading a micro
moves there. Um,
and looking at this kind of got an
uptrend here, but
you know, it's just I'm just going to I
want to try and just give this wiggle
room.
Okay, it's kind of in a there's not
really a good uptrend. It's in an
uptrend.
I mean, it's it's slowly moving here.
I'm going to move this to obviously
break even now.
Um, ideally like coming up to here is
where I would think we're going to slow
down.
Um, we've got these lows here. I think
we could slow down.
I don't really want to move up to here.
I think I'm just going to let this thing
play out with the idea of, hey, I might
have catch the low of the day
and I don't really care to
try and capture, I don't know, half an X
or 1x. I'd rather let it again have
movement to play. You know, I'm not
going to lose anything. Um,
you know, trying to figure that out. I I
I want it needs to get up to here before
I start trying to look at taking
profits.
Doesn't look good. doesn't feel good
holding through this pullback,
especially when I'm like, "Oh, well, I
could have just got out up here or, you
know, some kind of trend break right
here and, you know, still got $1,300."
It's It's funny in hindsight to be like,
"Oh, $1,300. I don't want that. I want
to wait and give it room." But then when
it just pulls back on you and knocks you
out at break even, you don't make any
money. You're like, "Oh, that's stupid.
I shouldn't have done that."
Kind of waiting for this. Feels good
emotionally to see that happen. If that
gets reversed, that's definitely not a
good sign.
Okay, now we are starting to get up here
and the big thing is just seeing what
are these pullbacks doing. You know,
every time we have a spike lower, it
gets gobbled up. Spike lower, gobbled
up. Spike lower, is it going to continue
to get gobbled up? Basically the idea is
just seeing is it getting gobbled up
still as we just you know are we just
continuously doing this? Um
I think we will we did kind of break
above this and spike lower and kind of
bottomed off of here. I don't see why we
couldn't you know this new high comes
and tests this area. I'm not really
married to this trend line. I'm more
looking at the structure and seeing,
okay, what are these pullbacks doing?
Um, you know, because here we broke this
trend line. It wasn't a great trend
line. There was some kind of trend line
here, maybe here. There wasn't, it
wasn't a good one, but this was a clear
trend and then that kind of aggressive
trend changed here and pulled back. But
it pulled back to an area that makes
sense and is healthy of where this kind
of was struggling here to break through
this previous high.
And so it broke that and then pulled
back to retest that and then continued
higher.
It's still in this uptrend. We're still
making higher highs, higher lows. The
scary thing with this kind of movement
is
it's there's a high chance that all of a
sudden it just spikes. Maybe not this
much obviously, but it spikes something
a and volatility increases. Now, we
could also get it the other direction
where it just it's consolidating,
consolidating, and it just starts to
accelerate. That would be amazing
obviously.
But until then, you know, it's I mean,
just kind of,
you know, same thing of just kind of
playing this how we we see fit. I I see
potential. We could come up here, pull
back and bounce. Um that would be maybe
the next previous high um that it was
resistance. You know, this is the last
big candlestick. Um and then we're, you
know, we're still just continuing higher
from there.
So there's the spike lower I was nervous
about.
Hopefully it doesn't eat too much. I
mean the thought would be maybe it comes
down to here. This is the previous
swing.
Um and you know again with just how
we've been we've been eating up those
those spikes.
And so just trying to look at and see
what that looks like. how that plays
out. Um hopefully it just kind of eats
it up. Um if it starts to, you know,
show some weakness or kind of make a
lower high.
Um I'll definitely try and close out.
Like getting one and a half would be
kind of nice. You know, I you can try
and give the market as much wiggle room
as possible, but at some point you do
have to manage it a little bit and not
just be, you know, oh, I'm I'm either
going to go break even or I'm going to
hit 10x. Like that's ridiculous, you
know. Um
you got to read the market and play with
what it's giving you, you know. And the
idea is you're there for when the
opportunities are there, but if they're
not
if they're not happening, you, you know,
manage accordingly.
The NASDAQ is kind of coming down to
this previous support zone, too. So,
this is definitely where I would want it
to hold in this uptrend.
The idea is
it could do one more spike here and then
continue higher. But this does look
pretty bearish. This looks pretty
bearish. You know, the idea is it's
still it's still just testing this area
and saying, "Okay, sold off, but are
buyers going to step back in?"
That's kind of what I'm waiting to see.
Kind of got this area, too.
I don't have too much more to do
management wise. Um,
you know, I want to see it have kind of
a pullback and make a push higher before
I move my stop below that
because I'm not looking to, you know,
get out on a spike lower in this market
that has been very strong with spikes
lower.
So,
but you know, this is where my stop is
going to be. I'm not really going to
move it.
I think that's plenty of a pullback to
hold through.
You know, it's hit the highs where I
think a lot of traders would have wanted
to close here. You know, seeing it slow
down and break this. This is definitely
people selling. This is people starting
to sell and be like, "Okay, I'm not
going to hold through this pullback.
It's, you know, hit the hit the opening
highs and kind of this trend line where
the easy money I think is is done."
Um, and you know, hindsight, if this
doesn't work out, maybe I should have
got out. But I think the trend is just
so healthy right now. And again, the
overall big picture of
this is not a great chart to look at.
Maybe I'll just pull up even even just a
daily chart. Um,
daily chart, you know, it's like I think
we're this is just a spike lower, a fake
lower, big picture, and we're going to
continue higher. Will could that still
stop me out and continue higher? Yeah.
But, you know, I think the big picture
bias is
long.
And so, trying to trying to
hold through the difficult pullbacks and
not let the emotions get scared and
wait for kind of to see what this
happens like. This is a nice strong
candlestick. NASDAQ is looking the exact
same. If this fails, I'm going to call
it and get out for sure.
because that's uh that's buyers coming
in and when buyers have stepped in, it's
just kind of continued higher after
that. You know, it hasn't done a double
spike lower. You know, maybe it did a
little a little higher low right here,
but it definitely didn't break the low.
You know, your swing low is put in and
it continues higher. So, I think I'm
actually going to move this up a little
bit because I think if it's, you know,
then if it breaks that big candlestick,
you know, it could have a spike here and
continue higher. But if it breaks this
big candlestick, I think that's a big
signal that okay, trend's over. Um, and
we're gonna
see what happens after that. Also, while
we wait for this to play out, I've just
made a free strategy guide that gives
you a full PDF of my strategy here and
kind of a stepbystep list of what I'm
looking for and kind of spots to avoid.
And so you can get that down in the link
in the description or this QR code and
it will just give you a really easy, you
know, done for you list to go back on to
look for um you know what to look for
and and how to consistently execute
this.
Well, we're climbing. That's nice.
I'm going to move this up here.
And this is a strong bullish push of two
candles. NASDAQ is looking to break as
well. I mean, it's nice sideways
movement
and still keeping that uptrend. Um,
we're just sitting right here waiting to
break this high. Okay, that high's
broken. I'm just going to remove this
uptrend. I'm going to clean this up a
little bit.
I mean, what we're really looking for is
here's the actual highs. Now,
we can actually break those and continue
higher.
Just sitting here waiting after we had
this move up, you know, it looks like,
okay, we might fail, might fail. Now it
just looks like we're going in a
we're we're doing a bull flag pretty
much at the highs here. You know, we've
kind of retested the high, the previous
high, and now we're just kind of maybe
looking to make our next leg up. Um
NASDAQ actually looks stronger.
It's already doing this.
And ES seems like it's about to follow,
too.
[clears throat]
In terms of stop, I mean, I'm letting
this break out, but probably just move
it up here.
Again, you know, this is this isn't
where my real stop is. This is a mental
stop. If we if we pulled back and
started to do something here, I'd
probably, you know, move it here. But
pretty much at this point is I'm looking
for this to make one more spike up here
I think and you know look to get out.
Holy.
That is not exciting. Please don't just
screw me.
I'm going to some news clearly just
popped. I think I'm gonna pull my stop
below that swing just because
it's gonna suck to get knocked out like
that, but I don't know what that could
be. I don't want to let it spike way
down.
The hope is that it just double bottom
there and it goes up. Um
I don't know. We'll see this that o
that's scary to see cuz it was just
cruising chugging along and if someone
just decided to
say something on the news or something
happened um it sucked to just have that
ruin a big trade. But it's totally
possible in a volatile time like this.
The hope is that that's just a weird
spike
knocks people out and now my stop's in a
good spot based on that and it, you
know, chugs higher. Um, if not, hey, I'm
getting out with still close to 3x of
profit. So, still really sick trade. Um,
NASDAQ, same exact thing.
Kind of holding this area. I think we
just got to see what happens here.
That's really intense all of a sudden.
Just got to breathe through it. Let it
do its thing. I move my stop in a good
spot. Maybe we get volatility in the
other direction. That totally could have
um started something.
But we could also just go back into our
sluggish move.
kind of crazy to zoom back and say that
I've stood here and watched this whole
thing since here.
And it's always crazy like when you're
in when you're entering in a trade and
thinking, oh, what's the likelihood that
this kind of does its you know moves up
like this or works out and and you know
in hindsight looking back oh this is a
obvious head and shoulders but you know
learning how to do that and enter when
you see that that's that's the harder
part. And then obviously managing this
trade has been extremely difficult. I
think this
um and hard and knowing when to when to
move the stop up and when not. I mean
that's just that's just takes practice
and experience. And so don't you know if
there's people in my room that have said
they they got stopped out and and stuff
like that and and that's totally fine.
Like it takes time
and and of course it just depends on
your your plan and your strategy and
what you're trying to do of
how you manage it.
NASDAQ's kind of hitting this area
definitely where I would think it would
start to slow down or just you know find
that um resistance. ES is already on a
five minute. All right. Looking great,
Maze.
I know, little puppy. I We haven't gone
on a walk at all.
[snorts]
As we wait for this, my dog
My dog is over here just looking at me
like, "Hello, what are you doing?
We should have been on gone on a nice
walk by now." And you're just standing
there way longer than normal.
You didn't poo on the carpet, did you?
No.
Good girl. I m I'm almost done. Okay.
You just have to be a little patient.
It's just how it is. Looks like might
get knocked out here.
I'm not moving my stop though. I'm happy
where it is.
NASDAQ even is looking a little
stronger, which is interesting.
But
looks like I got knocked out still like
$3,500 on a trade.
I think it was great a great trade.
Bummer that I didn't get out at a better
spot, but I mean, I think it was a sick
trade. Sick spot.
Could it just spike here and go higher?
Totally 100%.
Um, but happy to call it there and just
be done for the day. Make sure to check
out that new strategy guide for free in
the link in the description. Definitely
worth it for a nice easy visual of how
to use the strategy